listen to the music
read the text
think about the picture
where is the person here and where is
there none
is there something human here or not at
all
[Music]
but imagine a future where you could
read a book while a computer takes the
wheel it was another training trip for
Dean pomelo's unusual car the car was
one of the first attempts to create an
unmanned drone stuffed with some of the
most advanced albeit bulky electronics
at the time the car could be controlled
without human guidance
before crossing a bridge Dean let go of
the wheel once again handing over
control to the car suddenly the car
sharply veered to one side at the last
moment the inventor managed to get the
car back on track just a meter from the
abyss back at the laboratory pomelo
tried to understand the computer's
mistake or more precisely the
proto-neural Network's mistake it was
not controlled by an algorithm but a
self-learning program the network was
using the grass at the edge of the road
to determine its direction hence the
appearance of a bridge confused it
in this instance the driver survived 30
years later the outcome was more tragic
2022 China
a Tesla suddenly went crazy it hit a
cyclist and a pedestrian they died
the manufacturer stated that the human
factor was to blame and the driver
confused the gas with the brake but in
Chinese social networks they claimed
that for the last mile and a half the
owner lost control of the Tesla and the
car moved and accelerated itself
[Music]
we're afraid of the dark we're afraid of
the unknown but our greatest fear is
that of the unexplainable of that which
we created ourselves but can no longer
understand how or what it is thinking
it's fine to fear doomsday when it's
somewhere far off in the future and what
if this day has already come and no one
noticed it's just that in 2015
everything was more prosaic no walking
robots just an old board game and the
human intellect that preserved long
before the neural network
foreign
[Applause]
you wrote the code you'll be replaced
you're a logistician accountant loader
Taxi Driver neural networks will do your
work faster and for free
you're a broker investor crypto Trader
you won't be needed in five years
or maybe you're a designer journalist
marketer specialist about promotion in
social networks change your sphere now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this video was created by the some
subverification platform but more about
some sub innovate
[Music]
learning algorithms were named neural
networks based on an analogy of the
device with the human brain the complex
interactions of neurons in our head
somewhat resemble the principal workings
of the networks
we won't go into detail about how AI
works or we'll be here for hours here
are some videos that outline the key
principles of machine learning
the main point is that the network
consists of several levels external and
hidden it analyzes incoming data and
learns to find the necessary patterns in
them
patterns are analyzed in deep players
and the network will then give a result
algorithms can help perform routine
straightforward tasks which a human
would do slower and less accurately for
example fast and complex calculations
but the script will be stumped by more
subtle questions that wouldn't cause us
any problems for example telling the
difference between a dog and a cat
a neural network is a learning algorithm
that knows how to gather intelligence it
doesn't just execute a command it learns
from large amounts of data to understand
the main gist and predict a result
[Music]
after pulling the lever the ball rolls
around inside the slot machine bouncing
off obstacles and knocked out points
some just randomly call Believers others
calculate the strength and timing but
nonetheless there is an optimal force
and trajectory that will get the most
points in theory a person can find it
intuitively but the neural network will
need to be allowed to play this game
many times and in turn it will learn to
calculate the trajectory
[Music]
for the next iteration the network won't
choose the most obvious path but it will
again be the most effective
the human eye will not see logic in this
Brownian motion because again it doesn't
exist in the human understanding there
is only the result
the problem is that instead of the glass
cover of the slot machine we have a
black impenetrable box probably for the
first time ever people have created a
mechanism whose principal mechanisms
they do not fully understand it's like
looking through water the first few
meters it's transparent and then
Darkness
look at your smartphone you probably
have a modern version of the gadget take
any picture something completely random
and that fraction of a second that the
image turns from Cloudy and Overexposed
into clear and stabilized is all the
time that the two or four neural cores
of the smartphone processor need to
process and improve the image most often
there is not enough information in the
pictures the neurocore understands for
example that there is no focus on the
face in the frame
and it sharpens this fragment of the
photo almost as if it fills in the
missing pixels
it understands exactly what needs to be
improved or completed thanks to the
millions of pictures that it had already
studied here's the latest smartphone
from Google the pixel 7. it can make
sharper not only photos taken on the
device itself but any photo at all and
here is an equally impressive service
that can improve the quality of even the
most ancient photos taken at the
beginning of the 20th century on the
library of congress's website there is a
selection of the first pictures ever
taken in the United States let's see how
a neural network can improve this photo
this picture was taken in Alaska in
1868. it's a group portrait of
Representatives of a local tribe their
faces are fuzzy let's hand this photo
over to our neural network
[Music]
foreign
the difference is obvious
[Music]
the Specialists are the very same Google
brain team have trained a machine
learning model to turn low resolution
photos into high resolution detailed
images with almost no loss of quality
it uses an interesting method the low
quality image is mixed with digital
noise more and more noise to the photo
until the picture is obscured altogether
turning into nothing and then the
algorithm reverses the process gradually
removing noise from the image Guided by
the original low resolution picture
so it's almost as if the neural network
seems to understand or even know which
pixel or which exposure this or that
part of the photo should have there are
different variations of these networks
for example CDM which was trained on
more than 40 million high resolution
images CDM works cascadingly that is
first it generates a low resolution
image which gradually increases to the
maximum possible according to Google an
image with a resolution of 32 by 32
pixels can be enlarged up to 256 by 256
pixels without significant losses that
is 8 times an image with a resolution of
64 by 64 pixels can be completely scaled
up to a resolution of 1024 by 1024
pixels 16 times the same principle
applies to videos neural networks help
to remember your face for Face Unlock
and optimize the operation of
applications ungrateful is what the
developers who have been trying to teach
machines to understand our speech for
almost a 100 years would say this was
the first mechanism that could respond
to voice commands created in 1927 in the
USA the Herbert telecox robot was a
simple device in which various relays
reacted to sounds of different
frequencies there were three tuning
Forks in the robot Each of which was
responsible for its own tonality
one of the relays was turned on
depending on which tuning fork was
triggered
it was possible to communicate with the
telecox robot both by individual signals
with the help of a whistle and by short
verbal cues from tuning Forks laid out
in a sequence of sounds not so long ago
the height of this technology was a
visual interlocutor capable of
maintaining a long conversation with
Scientists in large Laboratories
now neural networks live literally in
your home Alyssa what time is it
what the hell is wrong with this blasted
thing for example you can actually see
how well neural networks can pass the
Turing test on this website this neural
network for talking to people was
written back in 1988 by British
scientists the number of chats it has
had over the years has exceeded 65
million
neural networks can paint a picture just
on a few given words just type in the
necessary hashtags
the new network mid-journey works
wonders combining different characters
in one picture essentially writing works
of art here is the story of a man who
Rose to popularity thanks to neural
networks he just became Tom Cruise this
naturally raises the question why film
the real Tom Cruise if his famous facial
expressions can be recreated by
artificial intelligence or are they
already doing this
how do you answer that question did you
notice that Tom Cruise in the new top
gun barely differs from his character in
the original film shot 30 years ago as
Technologies become more accessible soon
pretty much anyone will be able to
create a deep fake therefore we'll face
more and more criminals abusing this
tool to steal money identities and more
this begs the question how can we detect
all these fakes when they're getting so
realistic well some sub again has a
solution for that our in-house liveness
technology enables companies to detect
criminals using deep fakes to register
our liveness is a superior artificial
intelligence technology with seven years
of training data it detects even
Advanced forms of deep fakes and other
tricks used by fraudsters the solution
uses people-friendly facial Biometrics
that work equally well across the globe
it takes just two to four seconds for
authentic users to complete the check
resulting in Pass rates as high as 99
plus our aliveness solution has been
proven secure by ibeta tests how can you
implement liveness it suits a variety of
use cases such as biometric verification
for example when you need to compare the
user's face with the image on their ID
you can also use liveness to detect
duplicate accounts for face
authentication during logins or to
confirm risky actions if you want to
learn more about our liveness technology
see the link in the description this way
you'll stop all those fake Tom Cruisers
attacking your business
[Music]
this little Rover is carrying a package
most likely he took it from one of the
automated warehouses there Logistics is
also probably controlled by algorithms
and neural networks our self-driving car
when it happens will be electric largely
automated and surrounded by AI including
facial recognition
in China 80 of all jobs can be replaced
by smart technology in China's economy
demand is not limiting jobs and
resources instead Durand is increasing
by leaps in bounds for example smart
China 2030 making it real smart
infrastructure includes building smart
cities their AI systems will determine
whether and where parking is needed
letting drivers to rest we didn't notice
that we have ended up in the paradise
described by science fiction writers
artificial intelligence takes care of
boring tedious work freeing up time for
Humanity to be creative
but is it truly a paradise
pricewaterhousecoopers one of the
largest Consulting companies released a
study titled will robots really steal
our jobs and the forecast is unsettling
yes algorithms will take work away from
many and those first in line to lose
their jobs will be physical laborers
couriers movers taxi drivers Factory
workers
perhaps we will see what the British saw
in the early 19th century luddite's
riots then two a technological
Revolution broke out which fundamentally
changed production
technological progress meant that one
machine began to perform the work of
dozens of low-skilled workers
the luddite's movement became huge they
raided workshops smashed up new Planters
and steam-powered spinning wheels
it's easy to imagine a burning data
center in the background of a crowd of
newly redundant workers chanting
according to the estimate of PWC 37 of
workers already expressed concern that
artificial intelligence will replace
them and yes blue collar workers will
obviously be the first ones to suffer
but it would be worse for those with a
desk job not a question of enough pal
it's a zero-thumb game somebody wins
he loses do you remember how Gordon
Gekko made money from insider trading
which is totally illegal for a Trader
but now imagine that you were Guided by
events on the stock market and it's
absolutely legal okay robots have been
trading on the stock exchange for a long
time well algorithms in fact four years
ago eighty percent of transactions were
made by robots but AI Works differently
depending on how well the network is
trained it can predict Market changes
conditionally technical analysis
guarantees that the peak has been passed
and it's necessary to short but a neural
network suggests that the volatility is
such that the growth will continue and
will continue exponentially don't sell
wait and often artificial intelligence
turns out to be right
according to IHS markets in 2018 the
result of the use of AI by Financial
organizations was estimated at 41.1
billion dollars by 2030 this figure
could reach 300 billion dollars that's
what neural networks pick up the fastest
that is how to do the work of a clerk
and copywriters of all kinds a truly
exclusive product is created in units of
one in the engineering financial and
creative Fields the essence of the rest
of the work is often a copy paste or
compilation that is literally what AI
was created for of course people in
their own selfishness will be sure for a
long time and a robot Raider Symphony
can a robot turn a canvas into a
beautiful masterpiece
can you but the reality and we're
talking about genuine reality and not
futurology is that this is all they can
do yes while a thousand Euro monkeys sit
behind thousands of virtual typewriters
they cannot write war in peace as a rule
the network can't maintain a storyline
for a long time and on the second page
it forgets about the heroes that it
described on the first
although people have been attempting
this for a long time but nonetheless a
piece of text a short post a sales
article are all well within the
capabilities of the neural network
as for neural networks and music well
that's easy to talk about there are
dozens of shareware engines on the web
that compose tracks for which no one
needs to pay royalties for example
ampermusic.com we've composed a few of
Our Own
it's not Mozart but for the voiceover of
a video script written by a neural
network on YouTube is good enough by the
way are you sure that the text you're
listening to now is written by a person
write your thoughts in the comments
okay composing music inventing
advertising slogans and organizing
Logistics most people find with
entrusting this to the god from the
machine but what about trusting it with
your life
already learning systems are helping
doctors to make diagnosis so far
everything sounds logical many stories
of diseases and specific cases have
already been digitized and entered into
databases so idea of also developed
autonomous intelligence system that can
take all that data in real time process
it and then predict tricks or
complications not just one time but on
multiple occasions it's also not
difficult to teach the network simply
download a large amount of data and
diagnosis and identify connections and
then any diagnostician can use AI as a
tool
the accuracy of these neural networks is
only increasing a few years ago they had
an accuracy of 87 a good doctor will
correctly diagnose 86 cases out of 100.
now it's up to 97.
Atlas Advanced targeting and lethality
automated system can you think of a
worse name and even the explanation
autonomous targets acquisition
technology that will be integrated with
Fire Control technology aimed at
providing ground combat vehicles with
the capability to acquire identify and
engage targets at least three times
faster than the current manual process
didn't make the situation much better as
soon as information about the
development of this automated killing
machine got outs to the public a scandal
ensued and the military had to explain
that no artificial intelligence will not
decide for itself who to kill on the
battlefield this system was to help
soldiers but they will still need to
pull the trigger themselves
foreign have you ever seen salmon in the
wild a neural network was asked to draw
a picture of salmon swimming against the
current this is what happened
meta Ai and papers with code have
launched a demo version of the new
Galactica language model based on a
neural network this system was designed
for storing combining and analyzing
scientific knowledge however the system
was shut down a few days later users
started generating content with racist
and offensive content as well as
creating articles that resembled
scientific research the content of which
could lead to potentially dangerous
consequences now the neural network is
never wrong it gets results based on the
data it was trained on and if a person
doesn't like the results it's not the
ai's problem and the greatest Technical
and ethical task will be to create a
system that would ensure against AI
making decisions that might be harmful
for humans have you seen this picture
before it's called the trolley problem
save money but kill one or vice versa
many will die one will survive a
difficult choice that the person taking
the decision will think about for the
rest of his life and now think about
Tesla in China the algorithm the neural
network is devoid of reality so how can
we trust it with making vital decisions
and most importantly who is responsible
for the damage caused by artificial
intelligence let's imagine in the near
future that we have fully automated
taxis you call a taxi and before you sit
down you have to agree to the terms and
conditions just like how you accept
cookies on websites but you are agreeing
that the car is driven by one or another
AI this means that you understand and
accept the risks probably there will
start to be a hierarchy someone will
never get into a taxi under the control
of a neural network of a certain
manufacturer in the same way that at the
moment some people refuse to fly on
Boeing 737 Max due to the fact that two
planes crashed due to design errors of
the manufacturer but okay with cars you
can come to some kind of solution but
what about neural networks in medicine
networks can already predict the
development of dangerous diseases what
if the network recommends that a woman
have a mastectomy since she has an 80 to
90 chance of breast cancer and let's say
that the patient follows this advice
only to later find out that the neural
network was taught using outdated data
and the operation wasn't necessary at
all and the prediction of crimes
criminal records are already being
digitized in large volumes you can teach
a neural network to identify those prone
to relapse a certain social group
patterns of behavior this is just one
step away from The Minority Report
go
pay your attention to that man behind
the curtain who will be the judge maybe
AI will make the decision this is what
the first meetings under the leadership
of artificial intelligence in China look
like and in Estonia the use of neural
networks is already being introduced
into judicial practice to be honest it's
starting to sound a little scary not
because it resembles the scenario of a
bad dystopian movie but because of what
was talked about at the very beginning
that feeling of the unknown a black
opaque box
xai explicable artificial intelligence
is a neural network in which there is a
special block that explains how the
network made a particular decision
this approach is called a white box most
likely this is the future of AI
at any moment a person can pop the hood
and see what's happening
well like in a pinball machine
paradoxically the Advent of the era of
neural networks will of course deprive
many thousands of people of work but on
the other hand a lot of new positions
will appear developer will be the
profession of the future
teaching the network is an art you need
to correctly understand the goals
understand the coding and at the same
time be a narrow specialist a marketer a
journalist a musician no need to smash
up the automated planter it's not a
replacement for you it's your new tool
by the way have you noticed that
artificial intelligence has been adding
its own touches to this video if you did
pause the video and tell us in the
comments how you spotted that the
content was of artificial origin man had
a similar experience once a long time
ago when a new technology the principle
of which people did not fully understand
could both help and kill
it was fire several Millennia later and
he was understood and tamed
[Music]